what's your response to people who say
oh you twos for kids I mean I think it's
for kids now I think it is I think it's
I think most of what's on in the YouTube
space that's popular is is aimed at kids
but also I think the problem has been is
that in the last you know couple of
generations media and any all media has
sort of been made for specific age
groups so that literally wasn't the case
when I was a kid you know and I was a
kid growing up in the 70s you watched
what adults watched you know what I mean
it was there was there were only a
handful of channels there's only so much
program he was nothing compared to
what's out there now so if your parents
watched all in the family or mash which
which bike in peril Rhoda were Mary
Tyler Moore Bob Newhart any of those
shows that by comparison would be
considered adult shows there wasn't any
Nickelodeon there wasn't anything there
wasn't Hannah Montana there wasn't you
know any of this stuff that's like
targeted so I think what happened is is
that kids became the beneficiary of
watching stuff that wasn't necessarily
an you ended up reaching for that or you
ended up I would just remember thinking
like wow I that's what the adult where I
want to be there I want to that's that's
what it's gonna be like when I'm you
know going out or dating or married or
having a job that's gonna be I think I
think that's a good thing and a healthy
thing and I think that there's a lot of
material that plays down to kids and
then kids stay in that sort of you know
sort of stunted plays so yeah YouTube is
always going to be filled with you know
I think my sis my wife said somebody's
stuck like cinnamon up their ass or
something like that or ate or drank
cinnamon or something and that's got a
tea truly but that's the that's the
that's the content somebody drinking
like a jar of cinnamon or something I
probably sounds super all because this
is probably like has eaten Jillian hits
but that is different from you know an
episode of all the family and be
interesting to see if we can graduate
from cute kittens and people farting
fire to something that actually has
that's worth watching over 20 seconds
that actually
it's interesting and informative and
entertaining I think it can be that
controlled YouTube can be that but right
now it's in its infancy in a lot of ways
do you think though that's the symptom
of more times I mean most of these kids
have been around for September 11th
why do things pretty much change and
they maybe want something that's lighter
like when I was growing up there was a
show Family Christian family raid it was
you know I wonder if that's too heavy
now because the world is actually a much
heavier places Masons maybe although you
know when when you know in the 70s we
were like I remember we're still in
Vietnam we still had Watergate the
country was essentially I mean there at
the time that birthed like the last
great period of cinema you know are
everybody's you know the consensus is
the 70s was the last Golden Age was at
the time of them that are probably one
of the darkest periods in this country
in terms of people's sort of bubble
bursting opal it whether the president
is a crook and you know the war and
we're losing a war first war and it's
it's for what and and although you know
Afghanistan and Iraq make you know
Vietnam looked like nothing
comparatively so maybe it is I don't
know that I think there's always been
escapism people always want you know
whether it's during the Great Depression
people wanted you know musicals to
disappear you know into but I also feel
that if it only is that that that the
itself is sort of like the the
collective intelligence level just gets
lowered and lowered and lower until we
become like you know what like my judges
feel like idiocracy which is an
underrated movie where you just become
like this blob with like you know
sitting in front of a monitor which is
just like you know violence and porn and
having like you know liquid cheese fed
into your mouth I mean you can that's
where it's going you know where we're
going into this if you don't have any
real stimulus and that doesn't mean it
has to be heady you know that's so Tareq
entertainment if it's just like you can
still be funny and smart they could
still be action and smart then you
become brighter it's like if you only
read if you only ever read a comic book
that's the level of your literature
that's your that's that's unless you're
you know a genius
if
what you take in informs what you what
you like and what you put out and so you
have to digest something of substance in
order to be substantive in your own way
I think you know that's my thinking
you